Red and white striped, sometimes with a bit
of blue, a barber pole twisting next to a
small storefront signifies a place where men
can get a haircut, a shave and a bit of masculine
bonhomie.
But this was not always the case.
Back in the day, the red and white we associate
with good grooming used to represent blood,
bandages, leeches and pain.
Barbers through History
As long as people have been making razors,
there have been barbers.
In Egypt and other ancient cultures (as early
as 3500 BC), barbers were often priests whose
main job was to keep evil spirits from possessing
people; they did this by trimming, styling
and shaving off the hair through which demons
liked to enter the body.
This role morphed into something that much
more closely resembles a modern day barber
by the time of the Greeks in the 5th century
BC.
Setting up in an agora, the Greek barber styled
hair, trimmed beards and encouraged gossip.
In Rome, barbers were known as tonsores, and
many well-groomed Romans made a stop at their
shops part of their daily routine.
Even in the somewhat misnamed “dark ages”,
barbers were in demand.
Many monks, like the Benedictines, embraced
the tonsure, a hairstyle where the crown of
the head is shaved with only a narrow ring
of hair remaining.
Barbers were employed to manage this grooming,
and in addition, because of papal prohibitions,
barbers were also responsible for conducting
surgeries.
Historically, the Roman Catholic Church believed
that surgery violated the Holy Spirit’s
temple (the human body).
In line with this, several meetings of the
church, including the Councils of Tours of
1163 and 1179 and the Fourth Lateran Council
of 1215, decreed that priests and monks, who
had a long history of medical and surgical
scholarship, were forbidden from performing
surgeries.
Although priests continued to conduct research
and serve as physicians for the wealthy, they
relied on the barbers for surgical procedures
and bloodlettings.
In addition to the wealthy, barbers also helped
regular people.
Lancing boils, setting breaks and amputating
gangrenous limbs were common procedures; so,
too, was trepanning, a process by which a
hole was drilled into a person’s head to
let out the evil forces that caused mental
illness and epilepsy.
Bladder obstructions were treated with catheters
(sometimes inserted through an incision because
the syphilis-wracked patient’s urethra was
completely blocked), and kidney stones were
removed with minor surgeries.
But perhaps the procedure most commonly associated
with barbers in the middle ages was bloodletting.
Using a narrow blade, the barber would open
a vein and allow the blood to pour down into
a small brass bowl; by way of advertising,
many barbers would display these bowls of
blood in their shop windows so people would
know they performed the service.
During the procedure, the patient would grip
a white rod to encourage blood flow, and white
strips of bandage would be used to clean the
patient.
Dirty bandages were washed and hung to dry
on the grasping rod outside of the shop.
For those wounds too tender or hard to reach,
rather than lancing and bloodletting, the
barber would apply special leeches, known
as Hirudo medicinals, which emitted a natural
anesthetic and anti-coagulant while it sucked
blood.
These healthy, hungry leeches were typically
kept on hand in a separate brass bowl.
The Pole
The famous pole is a study in semiotics.
The white on the pole represents the bloodletting
rod that was grasped by the patient during
the procedure.
The red stripes symbolize the bloodied bandages,
often hung out to dry on the pole after they’d
been cleaned as well as possible.
As for the rest, things get a little murkier.
It’s is thought that the brass ball at the
top may represent the bowl of leeches, while
the brass at the bottom evokes the bowl that
catches the blood.
For those poles that have a blue stripe added,
many believe this represents veins.
Of course, sometime in the middle ages, the
profession of surgeon emerged, and afterward,
surgeons and barbers competed for customers.
To end the conflict, Parliament passed and
King Henry VIII approved legislation that
united both into the Barber-Surgeons’ Company
in 1540.
Subsequent legislation was passed that further
required barbers and surgeons to specialize
and distinguish between the two groups by
either having a red and white pole (surgeons)
or one that was blue and white (barbers).
So from this, perhaps the blue simply originally
represented traditional grooming services.
Whatever the case, despite the distinction,
in
the United States particularly, barbers
still tend to
use white
and red in their poles (usually spinning)
as well
as blue.
Rather than have its origins wholly in the
original meaning
of
the
color scheme, this
is thought
to have more to do with
the
fact that the U.S. flag is, of course, colored
red, white, and blue.